[Intro music]
People often go to school
with the mindset
that it's something
they're required to do.
Ever since we first learned
how to read numbers and letters,
it's been the social norm
to pursue a degree,
get a job, get married,
have kids, and so on.
Well, what does it
all mean in the end?
We celebrate graduations
because they mark
an important milestone.
But what does it mean
to be successful?
And more importantly,
does your mental health agree
with that image of success?
In truth, school isn't built upon
the foundation of promise.
For some people
who are more scholarly inclined,
school is where
they thrive and belong.
But what about those who feel reluctant
to follow the same path?
1. You're a night owl.
Teenagers who start school
before 8:30 am
have a higher risk
of developing anxiety and depression.
Early school start times
seem to put more pressure
on the sleep process
and increase mental health symptoms,
while later school start times
appear to be
a strong protective factor.
While early start times supposedly
help students develop
time management skills
and resilience to challenges,
exam schedules take
such a large toll
on students' health.
Because these issues haven't been resolved,
suicide remains the 2nd leading cause
of college student deaths
since the 1950s.
And as school enrollment increased,
so did the number of suicides.
2.The education system
can't keep up with
with the job market.
Today, there are jobs
that weren't available
in our parents' generation.
Now, technology,
creativity and entertainment
drives the economy.
Thanks to social media,
there's a higher demand
for online marketers, writers,
graphic designers
and computer programmers.
But the education system is failing
to catch up with these changes.
While the skills being
taught right now
are basic and essential,
they aren't enough for jobs
that are demand for newers' skills.
3.College is hard to afford.
It's hard to earn a college degree
with a middle-class wage.
But it's often advertised that
you'll need a college degree
to earn at least
a middle-class wage.
People from the lower class
want to go to school for a better life,
but are often unable to afford it.
In addition to paying for college,
many people ended up in debt
from student loans.
4.You have a big idea
and your school might not
be able to foster it.
Here's a fun fact:
14 of the world's
most successful billionaires
didn't earn a college degree.
They were passionate
about entrepreneurship
and decided school couldn't
turn their vision into a reality.
Mark Zuckerberg, the CEO of Facebook,
dropped out
during his sophomore year at Harvard
and founded Facebook in 2004.
Hiroshi Yamauchi,
the third president of Nintendo
dropped out Waseda University,
to take over
the family business.
Although these people
are known for their achievements,
there's no doubt that
they faced tremendous struggles
and many failures
before making the headlines.
You can have a plan
that doesn't involve school
and still be successful.
5.Your dream doesn't
require a degree.
63% of the degrees between now
and 2020
won't require a college degree.
Some of which include:
Construction supervisors,
electricians and insurance sales agents.
In addition, for individuals
who are hands-on learners,
and excel at
using sensory information.
Some of these existing jobs
are a great fit for them.
Because they don't involve
exploring the abstract ideas
or theories school often reinforce.
6.College doesn't prepare you
for the real world.
Starting at a young age,
we've been taught that
we must excel and
look good on paper
in order to succeed.
But all that does is reinforce
perfectionistic tendencies,
which is actually detrimental
to one's well being.
We're given the illusion
that gold stars and straight As
will ensure that we're
doing everything right.
and anything less is a failure.
Reality doesn't work
that way though.
Someone won't always
be there to recognize
and acknowledge
your hard work.
And failure is actually
a large aspect of life.
This is why
when college graduates
can't land
their dream job right away.
It hits them
like a ton of bricks.
7.The job market looks bleak.
School is supposed
to help students develop
important skills,
such as problem-solving
and time management
that will help them
take responsibilities
more readily.
But they don't mean anything
until they're applied
in the real world.
This is also why
companies are often reluctant
to hire recent graduates.
And since jobs
are scarce now,
there's more competition
between recent graduates
and those who've
already been in the industry longer.
8.Your degree
might become obsolete.
The career you wish
to pursue in the future
may no longer exist
by the time graduation rolls around.
Media and technology
have taken over
and replaced old jobs
with new ones.
So it's important
to consider
that the career options
you desire may be dwindling.
9.The "safe" route
isn't all that safe.
Even jobs that are in demand,
don't guarantee its safety net.
Medical and academic professionals
are facing more challenges
thanks to today's economy.
Doctors and nurses
are getting paid less
because of the way government
is regulating
the health care system.
And many teachers
are getting laid off
due to budges shortages.
Everyone's
scrambling for stability,
which has become a privilege
This is especially true
for Millennials, who make up
the most underpaid
and unemployed generation,
which is why
so many move back in
with their parents.
10.You are self-made.
By not choosing school,
you get to decide
how to acquire
the skills you want.
Going to school
and choosing one major
may limit what you learn.
On the other hand,
not going to school
can open
different doors for you
because you can explore
different options:
You can volunteer work,
attend workshops,
or participating online programs
to build
the skills you need.
And the best part is,
you can work and learn
at your own case.
So, do you think
schools are for you?
If you chose not to go to school,
what did you find beneficial
or hard to deal with?
We'd love to hear your stories
in the comments below.
If you enjoyed this video,
be sure to check out our website
and other social media,
as well as our new Patreon account
for more content.
And don't forget to subscribe!
Thanks for watching!